all ihr kennt nicht viel von der
heutigen welt sie hat weder zugang zur
fern werden computerspiele noch als
ihren handy zu anderen kindern hat sie
keinen zugang der was herzlich zum neuen
video leute freut mich dass ich heute
wieder eingeschaltet habe ich habe ein
neues video für euch am start wir haben
heute wieder einen zuschauer wurden in
der zeit in den urlaub fahren wir ja
fast zwei wochen keine videos
hochgeladen habe sind einige zuschauer
wünsche angelaufen dieses video ist
heute rein zu werden war auch dabei es
ist ein video von tafers lautet die wohl
ehrgeizigsten eltern der welt und das
zeigt eltern die mit ihrem kind sachen
machen also jetzt nicht so aber es ist
extrem leute glaubt mir wenn ich sage
dass dieses kind kein leben hat sie dann
unterschreibe ich schau mal rein
alia geht nicht mehr zur schule ihre
eltern und wann ich wieder heim denn so
sagen sie nicht in der schule lernt
unser kind nicht so dass du der erste
moment jetzt denken sich einige von euch
vielleicht edeka ali ali ali 18 jahre
alt geht nicht mehr zur schule wird zu
hause von ihren eltern unterrichtet
manch einer von euch denkt sich in dem
moment verdächtiger beste leben muss
nicht mehr die ganzen lehrer in der
schule sehen vielleicht manche
klassenkameraden ich keinen bock habe
aber aber wir ziehen die decke
ausbreiten muss jeden tag daheim büffeln
und ihre lehrer sind streng artikels mit
stoppuhr chemie englisch französisch
okay halt wir fest sie ist zehn jahre
alt das haben übrigens hat eben schon
gesagt weil ich mir die ersten 20
sekunden von diesem clip schon mal
angeschaut habe aber auch etwas abgeben
dieses video das erste problem heute das
erste aber bei dieser ganzen sache ist
dass folgen wenn ihr irgendwo lehrer in
der schule streit habt so wie ich euch
das mal streit hatte kam ich hatte
irgendwie so eine story meinte irgend
einen lehrer so blau oder machen wir das
und das nicht meint so zum lehrer das
geht auch freundlicher hilfe aufrecht
und dann drückte mir einen verweis okay
dann denke ich mir du hut der lehrer
denkt sich da gut wenn dein lehrer aber
dein vater ist ein sitzt der hut
du als für ihn da ist am abend beim am
esstisch zusammen das problem
[Musik]
ich hatte heute schon russisch und mathe
[Gelächter]
sorry leute sorry da kam gerade mein
gesunder menschenverstand draußen wollte
sagen so dass manche kinder vielleicht
irgendwo ein anrecht darauf haben kinder
zu sein
aber nein das haben sie natürlich nicht
kinder gerade ab zehn jahren haben eine
pflicht exotische fremdsprachen wie
russisch oder chinesisch zu lernen
pflicht ein rigoroses lernprogramm
abgestimmt darauf alias bedürfnisse so
nennen dass ihre eltern nicht zu ihnen
wichtiger als solides entwicklung ja
okay an allererster stelle eigentlich
erstmal cooles ziel von den eltern die
frage ist muss man es so geisteskrank
übertreiben es ist doch cool es ist gut
wenn eltern für ihr kind das beste
wollen wenn sie es auch fördern auch ein
bisschen pushen manchmal muss man sein
kind glaube ich auch bis in den arsch
treten muss ich meine weil kinder hat
auch wie sogar ein bisschen faul sind
manchmal nicht genau checken was ihre
handlungen gerade später im leben
auslösen können was aber im
umkehrschluss nicht heißt dass man die
eigene zehnjährige tochter zum cyborg
3000 züchtet er 80 stunden russisch am
tag herausforderung wir müssen uns wie
herkömmliche schulen immer neu überlegen
wie wir alle optimal fördern und uns ja
okay gut ja stimmt das glaube ich schon
klar als auch kinder zu erziehen ist
auch mit sicherheit viel arbeit aber
leute die frage stelle ich mir eine
frage ja ein kind was die gleiche
begabung hat wie zum beispiel diese alia
die auf ihre eltern scheinbar hier sehen
ja was eine normale schule geht und
normal gefördert wird wird auch seinen
weg gehen wird karriere machen wird sein
geld verdienen wird klar kommen wie viel
mehr bringt es diesem kind es zu hause
von den eltern treten zu lassen ihn mit
zehn jahren russische rhein zu prügeln
wie viel bringen was später in dem
300.000 euro einkommen im jahr statt
100.000 es ist wissen wir ja keine
kinder zu haben
die zehnjährige malia ist die einzige
tochter zweier ex akademiker die jetzt
live coaching praktizieren sie haben
malias unterricht komplett nach hause
verlegt also im ernst seite
frage stelle ich mir wirklich die frage
was bringt das dass das ist für mich das
was ich mich bei frage wenn ich das hier
sehe was bringt das also die freiheit
ist ja was bringt das soll jetzt will
ich mich geschlagen was bringt das über
eine normale schulbildung darüber hinaus
ist es diesen ganzen aufwand wert und
die antwort auf diese frage kann in
einfacher form von einem deutschen team
beantwortet werden live mit
militärischer präzision wird auch die
ernährung gramm für gramm geplant und
zudem macht ob ihre taschen speisen
kommen liefern kann könnte sich die
eltern nicht zumindest mal entscheiden
leute wollt ihr einen usain bolt als
kind haben oder wollt ihr ein albert
einstein
also das ist ja wirklich geisteskrank
warum denn beides kann euer kind ich
einfach genial sein oder ein sportliches
wunder muss es beide seien
definitiv zu den makro biotischen
speisen kommen literweise gepresster
gemüse sagt ja im namen des lärm regimes
was ist da ist lebertran oder was ist
das ss hands aus geriebenen
elefantenstoßzähne also man kann es auch
wirklich übertreiben das lernprogramm an
sich war schon übertrieben könnt ihr mir
glauben ist wirklich übertrieben bringt
es soviel gegenüber einem normalen
schulprogramm für die lebensqualität
will man nicht das also ist das ist die
frage die man sich stellen muss sollte
will man dass ein kind glücklich wird
oder wenn man dass ein kind eine
maschine ist wie arnold schwarzenegger
terminator und keine gefühle hat unser
ziel ist also zu ernähren
wie kann man denn so war es über sein
zehnjähriges kind sagen wie kann man das
sagte gal
dieses kind ist auf einem level auf dem
ich nicht mal cristiano ronaldo kenne
cristiano ronaldo einer der besten
fußballer aller zeiten der sein
komplettes leben seinen schlaf seine
ernährung alles durchgeplant hat ich
wette mit euch dieses kind ist auf einem
anderen level alias kein fan dieser
ernährung aber sie schluckt brav alles
noch ist sie nicht in der pubertät
dieser gepresste saft ist einfach
geklappt also ganz euro also das kind
tut mir wirklich leid mit mit sicherheit
auch leute ich glaube also was wir jetzt
so die einfachste erklärung die man
dafür haben kann keine ahnung die eltern
waren so mit ihrer eigenen karriere
nicht ein nicht zufrieden genug und
deswegen muss das klingt das jetzt reist
und deswegen wird das kind gedreht lasst
doch das arme kind kind sein fördern
okay ich kenne auch einige ich kenne
wirklich einige eltern die extrem
ehrgeizig mit ihrem eigenen kind sind
technisch trust wie aber keiner keiner
von denen hat sein kind kohl saft
reingepresst nachdem es gerade russisch
vokabeln auswendig gelernt hat 24
stunden am tag von ihren eltern
gefördert wenn sie nicht mit ihr
befördert ihnen voll strukturierte
freizeitaktivitäten im kargen hinterhof
an
im kernpunkt alia soll dabei immer
okay die zombie apokalypse trainiert sie
auch noch oder wie ok die wollen wir die
wollen wirklich einen super menschen
züchten diese eltern haben einfach so
ein kind bekommen und hatten eigentlich
nicht so bock auf ein kind die wollten
eigentlich so haben sie doch weißt du
was so ein cyborg wer eigentlich geil
außerdem lernen sie wie man mit scharfen
messern umgeht dann weiß sie wie sie
sich verhalten muss werden sie mal mit
solchen waffen in kontakt kommen neue
job wirklich ihr kind film zombie
apokalypse also ich will ich will ich
dieses kind sein sage ich ganz ehrlich
keinen bock drauf aber sollten wir
meinen die zombie apocalypse reinkommen
wir brauchen jemanden der 100 meter in
unter zehn sekunden rennen kann mit
pfeil und bogen exzellent schießen kann
wie legolas und zusätzlich noch schlauer
ist jetzt ein stein dann kümmern sie
zurückkommen alias kaum kontakt zu
anderen kindern die familie zurück
kurzem von wales nach brighton dem die
zehnjährige dort zwei mal die schule
gewechselt hause
artemis fowl habe ich dabei auch gelesen
als kleines kind
ob man jetzt tut mir wirklich leid der
ja das ist nicht cool
ich war eigentlich gerne in der schule
in welt ich musste einmal eine klasse
überspringen
die kinder waren okay aber natürlich
viel älter als ich ging so richtig
wieder der schule eigentlich ganz ganz
wohl gefühlt man mal papa kann ich
vielleicht doch mal an der schule
bleiben eltern so nein wie es einfach
spaß in deinem leben haben
rein rechtlich machen alias eltern
nichts falsch und dennoch macht sich
familienberaterin cattini thermen sorgen
um die entwicklung des mädchens und das
quasi ohne kontakt zu anderen kindern
aufwächst
ja das ist wirklich einfach es ist aber
schrott straight schrott in meinen augen
und es geht es ja nur meine meinung ist
es schropp alter wofür das ist dass die
firma stellt muss wofür was bringt das
was bringt das bringt das was ein kind
zu fördern und sein kind nicht zu
vernachlässigen so dass es keine ahnung
die schule abbricht und sein leben total
verkatert ja das bringt was es bringt
was ihm zu helfen kam ihnen durch die
schule zu pushen vielleicht ein studium
bot er war das ist gut aber dann warum
muss man von begleitende intensiv
begleitende eltern auf cyborg 3000
eltern gehen das muss nicht sein all
ihre kennt nicht viel von der heutigen
welt sie hat weder zugang zur fernsehen
computerspielen loch hat ihren handy und
zu anderen kindern hat sie keinen zugang
der was wird wozu hat sie den zugang
zugang zu russisch textbücher und zu
kohl saft marschall einfach die beste
kind hätte sagen müssen wie sie es also
sie es praktisch in gefängnissen mit
einem lern gefängnis wo sie gedreht wird
die gefängniswärter sind ihre eltern
man muss aber auch ein sozusagen das hat
die mutter gerade eben ein beitrag
gesagt ein bisschen zu lange um den hier
einzublenden das kontakt mit
gleichaltrigen was viele kritisieren
dass dieses kind nicht genug hat was ich
auch sagen würde auch nicht immer gut
ist das stimmt hat sie gesagt sie hat
gesagt an fast jeder schule gibt es
mobbing und das ist auch ein thema ich
kann mir vorstellen dass so ein sehr
intelligentes kind wie sie es
wahrscheinlich ist vielleicht öfter mal
aneckt und auch ihr risiko ist oder in
gefahr ist gemobbt zu werden könnte ich
mir vorstellen das ist ein vernünftiger
punkte nicht auf support lass mich dazu
unbedingt auch um eine wissenschaft
millionen kommentare rein trinkt teuren
rotkohlsaft lernt vokabeln ist ihr
vorschlag ist wie ab und hier um einen
kanal
ich finde schnell raus
das dann